we begin with a democratic presidential
race and the candidates trying to stop
mr. Trump from winning a second term six
of them met last night in the first
debate of 2020 it's their last meeting
before the Iowa caucuses the candidates
reached out to voters but a split
between senators Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders drew much of the
attention at the end it appeared that
Warren refused a handshake with Sanders
and O'Keefe covered the debate in Des
Moines and tell us what lies behind this
disagreement well good morning the
dispute between Warren and Sanders began
on Monday and became a major flashpoint
last night when the moderators brought
it up bottom line Warren says that
Sanders once told her that he doesn't
think a woman could be elected president
and Sanders denies he ever said that
well as a matter of fact I didn't say
senators Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren longtime allies now say they
remember a 20-18 conversation
differently anybody knows me knows that
it's incomprehensible that I would think
that a woman could not be President of
the United States what did you think
when senator Sanders told you a woman
could not win the election I disagreed
Bernie is my friend and I am not here to
try to fight with Bernie but look this
question about whether or not a woman
can be president has been raised in it's
time for us to attack it head-on can a
woman beat Donald Trump look at the men
on this stage collectively they have
lost 10 elections the only people on
this stage who have won every single
election that they've been in are the
women Amy
but that was at the end of it after the
debate Warren and Sanders appeared to
exchange words and parted ways without
shaking hands with Tom Styer looking on
he described it to us afterward we could
tell that the body language was a little
awkward right I think they were trying
to figure out something between the two
of them but I didn't really hear what it
was on stage the senators running for
president made clear their stance on the
upcoming impeachment trial this is a
decency check on our government this is
a patriotism check it is about Donald
Trump
putting Donald Trump first the
contenders also debated health care I
think we need to be candid with voters I
think we have to tell them what we're
gonna do and what it's gonna cost
climate change
I would declare a state of emergency on
day one on climate and a week after the
United States came to the brink of war
with Iran the candidates also debated
who had the best foreign policy
experience we should not send anyone
anywhere unless the overwhelming vital
interest the United States or at stake
but what I understood from right away in
terms of the war in Iraq the difference
here is that the war in Iraq turned out
to be the worst foreign policy blunder
in the modern history of this country
it's going to take a view to the future
as well as the readiness to learn from
the lessons of the past and for me those
lessons of the past are personal just 19
days remain until the Iowa caucus and
now we're really entering uncharted
waters because today senator Sanders
Warren and Klobuchar head back to
Washington to deal with that impeachment
trial while candidates like Joe Biden
and pee Buddha Jets get to stick out
here and with that trial beginning and a
campaign going on at the same time it's
gonna be interesting to see which of
those ultimately gets more attention
here in Iowa yeah and there does there
indeed seem to be a rift between Sanders
and and Warren I guess the question is
in Iowa there is there a sense that it's
hurting either of them well look if you
have to spend valuable airtime in a big
debate explaining that you're not sexist
you're probably not in good shape and
and Sanders had to do that last night so
probably not great for him but this much
we know over the past year Iowa
Democrats have told us repeatedly they
would rather see the candidates focused
on what they
to defeat the president and what they
would do as president then beating up on
each other so this does have the
potential to backfire on Sanders and
Warren leaving Biden and Buddha judge
and Klobuchar as potential options but
of course only two of those three will
be here so again this impeachment trial
has the potential to really upend things
over the next two weeks and change all
right and Warren definitely did not
throw a lifeline to her friend there
Bernie Sanders thank you very much I'm
curious a lot is being made about she
didn't shake his hand she was snubbing
him some people say look she didn't see
his hand extended you were there what
did you think well we weren't in the
room but by watching that footage you
know and if we had the telestrator maybe
we could really analyze it it definitely
looked like there was an awkward moment
that these two are good friends
they have been closed for years that was
an exchange that suggests that they're
having a big disagreement all right ed
O'Keefe I know we'll see you again
thanks a lot
you